The Fastest, Most Direct Way to Learn a New
Language in 8 Lightning-quick Steps
1.
Set language-learning goals.
The first step to learning a new language
fast is to set goals for what you want to
achieve.
When you think about it, this makes a lot
of sense.
If you don’t set goals, how can you know
what you want to achieve and measure whether
you have achieved it?
When faced with the idea of learning a new
language, most of us feel overwhelmed.
There are so many words to learn and so many
different ways to study.
Setting goals narrows your focus so you can
stop worrying about the details and get down
to business.
Research shows that people who set the right
kind of goals are more likely to achieve success.
Use these guidelines to get the most from
your goals:
Focus on specific, tangible outcomes.
Set detailed goals, and focus on what you
plan to learn rather than how much time you
plan to study.
An example of a good goal might be, “This
week I’m going to learn 30 Spanish vocabulary
words related to shopping.”
Set short-term goals.
It’s good to have an ultimate goal—the
thing you eventually hope to achieve.
But long-term goals are too overwhelming to
motivate you on an everyday basis.
Break down your ultimate goal into smaller
bits, and set smaller goals for each week
or month.
Challenge yourself (but not too much).
Goals work best when they make you push yourself.
But if they’re too daunting, they can actually
discourage you.
A good way to get around this is to set goals
with a range of outcomes.
For example, you might say, “I want to learn
30-50 new vocabulary words this week.”
The lower number in this range helps you feel
the goal is achievable, while the higher number
allows you to push yourself.
Write down your goals.
Writing down goals helps you commit to them.
Post your goals in a prominent place, like
your bathroom mirror or the home screen of
your smartphone.
2.
Learn the “right” words.
Languages are made up of a shocking number
of words.
English, for example, has between 600,000
and 1 million words.
Luckily, you don’t need to learn anywhere
near that many words to be proficient in a
language.
Consider this: the top 100 words make up about
50 percent of English language texts, and
the top 1,000 words make up about 90 percent!
Check out these lists of the top 1,000 words
in these languages:
Spanish
French
German
Japanese
By focusing on learning these words first,
you can eliminate wasted time and increase
the amount of information you understand very
quickly.
3.
Study smart.
When learning your words, you’ll learn faster
by using the very best study techniques.
For example, one of the best ways to learn
vocabulary words is to use flashcards.
Flashcards help you focus on individual words
and allow you to test yourself, which helps
you memorize new information.
When you learn with flashcards, follow these
tips to learn fast:
Try out electronic flashcards.
Paper flashcards work just as well as they
ever did, but electronic flashcard programs
like Anki provide some great benefits.
By using electronic flashcards, you can easily
carry large stacks on your smartphone or tablet,
and you can take advantage of flashcards that
other people have created and made public.
These programs also automatically change the
order of cards and use spaced repetition to
gradually increase the amount of time between
repetitions of a flashcard.
Both of these techniques help you learn faster
and better.
To maximize your use of SRS programs and electronic
flashcards, check out polyglot Olly Richards’
Conversations course, which is designed to
help you set up workable, step-by-step systems
for learning your target language.
You can also get more targeted help with the
Uncovered courses, which introduces the basics
of specific languages including Spanish, French,
German and Italian.
Make sure to guess the meaning of a word before
turning over the card.
Flashcards work best when you use them to
test your memory, so don’t be too quick
to flip the cards over.
Even if you don’t know a word, make a guess.
Learn the translations first, then learn to
produce the new words.
It’s easier to learn the translation of
a foreign word than it is to learn to say
the foreign word when you see its English
equivalent.
Start by looking at the side of the flashcard
with a foreign word on it, and memorize what
the English translation is.
Later, turn the cards over and use them to
practice producing the foreign words when
you see their English equivalents.
Practice makes perfect, but effective practice
makes perfect even faster!
Some more great strategies for integrating
new words alongside and beyond flashcards
include:
Visualize and vocalize.
Visualize the word you’re learning, imagine
the image of what it represents and say the
new word aloud.
This helps you connect the concepts and can
improve memorization.
Gesture.
The brain learns better when you use physical
actions while learning.
Take advantage of this by gesturing.
If you want to learn the German word Schuh
(shoe), say the word while you pretend to
put on a shoe.
Use FluentU.
FluentU provides unique, in-context learning
that goes way beyond regular flashcards.
FluentU takes authentic videos videos—like
music videos, movie trailers, news and inspiring
talks—and turns them into personalized language
learning lessons.
You can try FluentU for free for 2 weeks.
Click here to check out the website or download
the iOS app or Android app.
FluentU Ad
Try FluentU for FREE!
Use the word in your native language.
When you’re learning a new language, it
can be hard to practice words in context because
you haven’t yet mastered enough vocabulary
to make complex sentences.
To get around this, simply use the word in
your native language.
For example, if you’re learning the Spanish
word casa (house), you could say, “I’m
going to go to my casa now.”
Keyword technique.
Make up a sentence with the new word you’re
learning, the meaning of the word and a word
in your native language that sounds similar.
For example, if you want to learn the Spanish
word mesa (table), you could think of an English
word that sounds similar and make up a sentence
like, “My kitchen table is always a mess!”
Since “mess” and mesa are very similar,
this can help you remember the new word.
4.
Start using the language all day, every day.
As a beginner, it can seem overwhelming to
try to use the language all day, but it’s
not as difficult as it seems.
There are many easy and even fun ways to make
the language a part of your regular life.
First, make use of every moment you have to
learn new words.
Take flashcards with you, and study them during
your train or bus commute (but not while driving,
please!) or when you’re waiting to meet
a friend.
When you start to feel tired, switch from
active learning to passive learning by doing
what you would normally do in your native
language in your target language.
Try watching a video or TV show, or streaming
radio broadcasts in your target language.
There are many online resources to access
entertaining audio and video clips.
You can go to YouTube, search for radio stations
available on the Internet or use FluentU.
You may be asking, “How can I possibly watch
a video or listen to the radio when I only
know a handful of words?”
The goal when you start is not to understand
everything you hear but to familiarize yourself
with the sounds of the language.
Even if you don’t understand much of what
you hear, simply listening can have many positive
effects, including:
Becoming accustomed to the cadence of the
language.
Learning to identify and understand common
words.
Learning to understand using only context
and a few cognates.
Staying motivated!
5.
Seek out real-life practice.
Some of the best learning happens in real-life
situations, particularly when you have no
choice but to use a foreign language.
The easiest way to gain real-life practice
is to travel or study abroad.
Going abroad creates opportunities to be surrounded
by people who speak the language you want
to learn, many of whom don’t know your native
language.
This is the favorite approach of organizations
like the Peace Corps, which regularly places
people with little or no knowledge of a language
into full immersion situations.
Although such situations can be uncomfortable,
they provide enormous motivation to learn
quickly.
But even without traveling abroad, you can
immerse yourself in real-life situations that
give you loads of language practice.
Try these options:
Meet with a language partner weekly or biweekly.
You might pay your language partner for his
or her time or offer to exchange one hour
of practice in the language you want to learn
for an hour of practice speaking English.
Join a conversation club.
Many cities and schools have conversation
clubs where language students meet regularly
to practice having informal discussions in
their target language.
Use an online tutoring or language partner
site.
Sites such as Coeffee.com or My Language Exchange
can introduce you to people who speak the
language you want to practice.
Even if you don’t see them in person, you
can gain real-life language practice by chatting
online.
Volunteer with immigrants in your city.
Find volunteer opportunities on a site like
VolunteerMatch or Idealist, or directly contact
organizations that serve immigrants who speak
the language you want to learn.
Visit businesses where people speak primarily
your target language.
Perhaps there’s a Mexican restaurant nearby
where you can enjoy delicious food and practice
your Spanish with the waiters or owners, or
perhaps you can practice your Chinese at a
grocery store that sells food to the local
Chinese community.
6.
Learn about the culture.
Understanding a language is about more than
understanding words on a page.
It’s important to learn about the culture
and history associated with these words.
Knowing something about a country or culture’s
history, current events, religious beliefs
and common customs can help you understand
a lot about what people say and do.
Researchers have found that children learn
to read in a second language better when they
understand the culture and context behind
the pieces they read.
As you begin to study a new language, take
some time to learn about the culture of the
people who speak that language.
Don’t feel this is a waste of time, even
if it involves reading and watching videos
in your native language.
It will help you enormously and can even prevent
you from making embarrassing and potentially
offensive mistakes.
7.
Test yourself.
Knowing that you plan to take a test is a
great way to motivate yourself to learn faster.
Try to regularly test yourself in little ways.
If you’re learning from a textbook, take
practice tests or complete the exercises at
the end of each chapter.
You can also play online games or take online
tests.
Online practice tests can be found in almost
any language, including French, Spanish, Japanese
and German.
Planning to take a standardized test several
months to a year after you begin learning
a new language can also keep you motivated,
and having the results can help you “prove”
your language level to potential employers,
schools or even just yourself.
The ACTFL OPI test is popular in many language-learning
circles and widely respected.
It tests oral proficiency and provides a score
that ranks your level anywhere from “Novice
Low” to “Superior.”
Some languages also have a standardized test
specific to that language, such as the JLPT
for Japanese or the HSK for Chinese.
Ask teachers or professionals who know the
language what tests they recommend.
8.
Have fun!
We tend to learn best when we’re enjoying
ourselves, so don’t forget to make language
learning fun.
Playing games is a great way to have fun while
learning.
Games take advantage of our natural competitiveness
and can help us practice language skills even
when we feel tired.
You can also focus your learning on things
that you find interesting, like a favorite
hobby.
If you like to sew, for example, study words
in your target language related to sewing,
watch instructional sewing videos and talk
with tailors who speak your target language.
If you’re learning French and fascinated
by French politics, learn words used to describe
political processes, and immerse yourself
in articles about political issues, videos
of political debates and talk shows about
current events.
Finally, make friends who speak your target
language or are interested in learning it.
Languages aren’t meant to be learned in
a vacuum!
Real-life social events and conversations
are what make language learning fun and worthwhile.
Make a point of talking to people and learning
more about their lives and cultures.
You might be surprised at how excited they
are to share information with you, and how
quickly you make lasting friendships in the
process.